tonight on the new reality this is a
humanitarian crisis that we're dealing
with lives are at risk right now
nishkanika has the longest running boil
water advisory in
canada you hate to see your relatives
your children your future living in this
condition
and there seems to be no end the 260
people that live here
haven't had access to clean drinking
water for 26 years
it doesn't matter how many billions and
millions they spend
on indigenous projects the underlying
model remains
broken and they don't seem to want to
fix it we're still
thought of as less than human
as objects as things as a problem enough
is enough
i want to be able to turn on my
top and drink drink the water
welcome to the new reality i'm donna
friesen turning on the tap and getting
clean fresh drinking water is something
most of us
take for granted yet it is still a dream
for people in dozens of first nations
across this country
global news has been part of a year-long
investigation that's
shining a spotlight on communities which
don't have clean drinking water
some of them have endured this for
decades despite government funding and
multiple promises
as christa hesse explains the pandemic
has made the situation even more dire
this is nishkandega first nation a
remote flying community
in northern ontario though it doesn't
usually look like this
the entire community was evacuated a
week ago to thunder bay
after an oily sheen was discovered in
their water reservoir
a handful of residents have stayed
behind to keep the houses warm so the
pipes don't freeze
and to make sure the dogs are fed but
even that
hasn't been easy having no running water
means they can't bathe
or even flush their toilets
so the residents that are left here have
to wade into the freezing lake to fill
jugs of water
to fulfill those basic needs lawrence
sachani has lost count of the jugs of
water
he's used i've been my family
has been evacuated since seven days
already
so this is how much i used since they
were gone
nishkanika has the longest running boil
water advisory
in canada the 260 people that live here
haven't had access to clean drinking
water for 26 years
and many of the community's younger
residents have never drank the water
from their taps
nishkanika chief chris muniz says it
pains him to see the conditions his
people have to live in
you hate to see your relatives your
children
your future living in this condition and
there seems to be no end
and look at all the sludge in here
this was before evacuation this is the
second evacuation the community has
experienced
in recent years sharon sacheny is the
health director in nishkanaga
she estimates that she treats two people
a week that have rashes
and scabs connected to the water enough
is enough
i want to be able to turn on my top and
drink
drink the water it has been a week since
the community was evacuated
and today is the first time an engineer
from indigenous services canada has come
to assess the situation
wayne muniz an adviser to the chief says
the government
isn't doing enough this is a
humanitarian crisis that we're dealing
with lives are at risk right now
all we do is get water buckets of water
at the lake
to try to figure out a way how we're
going to live every day
since 2015 the trudeau government has
pledged more than two billion dollars to
address the water crisis in first nation
communities
and part of that strategy has been to
build and upgrade water systems on
reserves across canada
a year-long investigation by
universities and media organizations
including global news
aptn news and the institute for
investigative journalism
reveals government policies and a lack
of oversight has led to allegations of
flawed and
incomplete work being done on first
nations endangering the health of entire
communities
so often we'll go in afterwards and talk
to water treatment plant operators and
they'll say
well we expected them to give us
something that's functioning and this is
not
jessica vandenberg is an engineer and
consultant
who works with indigenous communities on
infrastructure projects
she's a 60s scoop survivor from denata
first nation
nishkanaga's water treatment plant was
built in 1993
but only two years later the community
came under a boil water advisory
for years the community has tried
unsuccessfully to secure funding through
the owner's government system
in order to build a new water treatment
plant but instead of a complete overhaul
the government greenlit upgrades to the
plant in 2015.
when it comes to indigenous communities
the money flows a little differently
it flows through indigenous services
canada it has a lot more hoops to jump
through
for money and funding for infrastructure
to get to the communities
in order to get funding first nations
have to complete feasibility studies
and prepare project proposals once
that's submitted to indigenous services
canada
nations can find themselves in a long
line of worthy applicants
so if you're not picked for year after
year after year after year
your study is getting older and older
and older and populations are growing
and existing infrastructure is
deteriorating sometimes very rapidly
once a proposal is picked the nation
will begin a tendering process allowing
companies to bid on contracts for the
design and construction
on paper first nations should have the
final say in who they work with
but that's not always the case
nishkanega reached this phase in 2017
and the community hired kingdom
construction limited to do the upgrades
the work was scheduled to be complete in
just under a year
but it wasn't long before problems arose
after a series of delays
leadership terminated its contract with
kingdom in early 2019
today work on the community's water
treatment plant is still not finished
and the cost has nearly doubled in a
statement kingdom said the situation on
the ground
was materially different than what it
expected based on the contract
and that a few large issues caused
delays chief muniz has also weighed in
on the tendering process
we are forced to pick the lowest bidders
and you know
then there's cost overruns that just
keep going up rather than putting
quality management first
its lowest cost the lowest cost may not
come from a company that has the trust
of the community nor necessarily puts
the community's needs first
it doesn't matter how many billions and
millions they spend on indigenous
projects the underlying model remains
broken and they don't seem to want to
fix it over the years
charlie angus a member of parliament for
timmins james bay
has dealt with communities frustrated
with the government system which can be
traced back to the creation
of reserves despite historic treaties
outlining a nation-to-nation
relationship
the indian act of 1876 forced first
nations into reserve lands
and put them under federal control by
law it's
astounding that it took you know the
forced evacuation of an entire community
to shine a light on this kind of
constant mismanagement but this is the
reality that's happening on the ground
in so many first nation communities
testing revealed the sheen in
nishkanaga's reservoir was due to a
non-toxic mineral oil that came from a
broken pump
but since the evacuation the water
system has had even more
problems the upgraded facility sewage
lift station
and distribution lines have all had
issues further delaying the community's
return home
that's our lift station right here and
this is one of the problems we have
nishkaniga leaders have now called for
an investigation into the business
practices
of the contractors and engineering firms
that have worked on their water system
we have to question why we have to go
through
through all this 25 years 26 years is
dehumanizing
several chiefs across the country said
the government's requirement that
nations work with the lowest bidder
has prevented them from hiring who they
wanted when pegus first nation in
manitoba put out a tender for upgrades
to the community's water treatment plant
in sewage lagoon in 2018
they wanted to hire a local contractor
to do the work
but in a phone interview peg was chief
glenn hudson says
in the end they also had to work with
kingdom construction on the nearly 12
million dollar project
we had local contractors but because
kingdom was the low bid we we weren't
able
to select them does isk essentially just
say you don't have any choice you have
to
you have to go with this yeah yes
contractor yes
yeah and given that it's our project we
demanded
that we wanted to um look at changing
that contractor
but yes ended up stating that they would
pull the funding
for it if we didn't follow that due
process
after delays and a communication
breakdown pegus terminated the contract
and asked kingdom to leave today he says
the community is still dealing with work
that doesn't meet code
puts operators at risk and threatens to
contaminate nearby waterways
and they're not being held accountable
when it comes down to
the project going off the tracks they're
saying well it's you guys money it's
your project
but they're the ones that steered us in
this direction peguis has now hired
local contractors to complete the
upgrades that should have been finished
two years ago withoxing first nation
sits along the eastern shore of georgian
bay in ontario
the nation also hired kingdom to build
its water treatment plant
back in 2010 due to the government's low
bid policy
ryan tobagan is the director of public
works here
he says that while the treatment plant
delivers clean water today
they experienced several problems with
the company we were basically in the
position where
if we didn't go with the low bid then
wasaks would be responsible
for the additional cost between the two
bids we contacted their references
there was a history of bidding low and
submitting a lot of extras to make up
for that low bid they assured us that no
that's not
that's not the case but ryan alleges
that's exactly what happened
he says that even though the project was
finished in 2012
it was delayed by 11 months and over
budget
ryan says kingdom requested several
change orders
a move that the project team felt was
premeditated
we felt we were threatened a couple
times in terms of
pay this or we'll pull our guys off
knowing what we know now
and the amount of extras that we we paid
to that contractor
we would have been better off going with
that other little bitter
jessica says extra costs are common on
any infrastructure project
but when it comes to work on first
nations in general she has witnessed
cases where charges have gone beyond the
usual
often they'll be over charging and
they'll be
invoicing of work that isn't done and
then the work that is done is often poor
quality
sometimes communities have to cover
these costs themselves
but often they have to go back to
indigenous services canada to request
more money
nastasia pickles is the water operator
in wissoxing
she was involved in the water treatment
plant's construction and says
she witnessed kingdom employees failed
to adequately fix problems and face
sexist comments from workers
they blew this pipe right out one day
one friday
the whole water plant was covered in
water and they duct taped it back
together
like for the weekend like they didn't
attempt to replace it or anything and i
was mopping up the mess and one of the
one of the workers he's like oh last
time i was here you were cleaning and
this time you are again that's the right
job for you
i was very upset and i'm like oh my god
like i passed my tests and
i deserve to be here when it comes to
first nations
there's already some layers of
stereotypes
and discrimination and racism and
prejudice as well
that sometimes will deter companies and
consultants and contractors from working
with those communities so communities
depending where they
are don't always have a lot of options
one first nation told global news and
its partners it was satisfied with
kingdom's work but when ryan gets calls
from communities asking if he would
recommend working with the company
he doesn't mince words my answer was no
kingdom also says it is not aware of any
evidence of racism by the company
or its employees and that they take
these types of allegations very
seriously
in a phone interview with aptn's melissa
ridgeon the president of kingdom
construction said
his company wanted to avoid first
nations projects in the future
it's a bunch of free money given to
people for nothing
that they never paid for necessarily i'm
not saying that in a rude way don't get
me wrong melissa i'm just saying
as a contractor we're looking at
millions and millions of dollars being
given from the federal government to the
native band
landry later apologized for the language
he used and acknowledged it was
culturally insensitive
kingdom denies any allegation that its
work did not meet the highest standards
including in nishkanaga adding that in
any project
there can be unforeseen expenses and
potential delays
and that additional costs are always
approved by the design engineers
the company also says it is bound to
perform all work as per the contract
and cannot speak to the suitability of
the end product as it relates to the
owner's expectations
documents show that federal officials
were aware 10 years ago
that wissoxing faced issues with kingdom
but the company continued to be hired
for work on first nations
eventually getting at least seven
projects valued at 90 million dollars
though the total received by kingdom is
unknown
coming up on the new reality we do our
best not to force any particular
community into a particular path
it sounds like deferral of
responsibility and accountability
rather than a collaborative approach
between
government to nation
the federal government is poised to
break its promise to end all boil water
advisories in first nations communities
by march a joint investigation with
global news reveals
allegations of incomplete and faulty
work plus
delays and overcharges those are some of
the concerns from first nations
communities
that we took to the minister responsible
for indigenous services
again here's christa hesse in an
interview
indigenous services minister mark miller
wouldn't comment on specific contractors
but said the findings of our
investigation were startling
the reporting that you and others have
done was certainly alarming
issues with kingdom were flagged as
early as 2010 yet the government awarded
the company six more major water
projects
after that why did that happen these are
our decisions that are taken with the
community
we do our best not to force any
particular community into a particular
path
it sounds like deferral of
responsibility and accountability
rather than a collaborative approach
between
government to nation according to
indigenous services canada's guidelines
first nations should award the contract
to the lowest acceptable bidder
provided that the contractor's tender is
complete and they appear capable of
doing the work
the department spokesperson said this
policy follows industry standards
does it follow industry standards yes it
follows historic practice
but it's not the best practice minister
miller has admitted that problems with
contractors are widespread
yet indigenous services canada does not
currently have a system to track
complaints and bad companies
that work on first nation water projects
the fact that they would claim that they
don't bother to check whether or not the
job gets done right
speaks to the to the systemic negligence
indigenous services canada will put
their check mark and say oh
that water treatment plan was replaced
you no longer need funding for the next
x amount of years
and who pays a consequence is all the
members of that community
we asked minister miller if he would
commit to tracking complaints about
contractors
going forward i'm keen to have as much
data
as possible and if it's helpful in
ensuring that
the people aren't the subject of sharp
practices i'm glad to do that
members of nishkaniga first nation have
now been living in a hotel in thunder
bay
for two months cases of coven 19 have
been on the rise
as the country grapples with the second
wave and residents
are worried marissa saccone is a mother
of two
who had to evacuate with her daughters
their girls picked a spot
back home when they said that we were
getting evacuated i said
no of course my partner talked me out of
it
marcus muniz marisa's partner is one of
the water operators in nishkanaga and
had to stay behind
she says her eldest daughter maya has
been struggling she had her
like her face on her knees
like she was sad so i asked her
to tell me how she feels and then she
says
she feels trapped marissa is 25 years
old and has never had access to clean
drinking water at home
she says just to prepare a bath can be a
two to three hour ordeal
it's very difficult carrying four five
five containers of ten liter water
taking it all the way to your house the
government advises people living under a
boil water advisory to not be
children or elders in the tap water but
often
people have no choice the only access to
clean drinking water in the community
is a reverse osmosis machine located in
a tiny shed on the edge of the reserve
and it often breaks down marissa says
her daughters have suffered from skin
rashes and sores
and that the outbreaks have caused her
to sometimes be scared to bathe them at
all
but despite these challenges she wants
to go home
even if the boil water advisory is still
in effect
we did it before so
we could do it again
i got a pack just a week before
christmas the community got news it
would be able to return to niskanega
finally it was time to go home
the water is running again but the
community's problems are far from
solved the boil water advisory is still
in effect
and work on the treatment plant has
slowed because of the pandemic
so for now they will continue to rely on
shipments of bottled water
the federal government has agreed to
investigate the contractors that worked
on niskanega's water system
and is working with the community on a
long-term plan to lift the boil water
advisory
but chief munius says he believes it'll
take an entire generation
to heal people's distrust for the water
we need to
work on the the trauma that they faced
over
over 25 years nobody can say
he said no you trust the water now
nobody can say that to them the federal
government has paid kingdom
nearly two million dollars to settle a
legal claim launched by the company over
its cancelled contract
the consequences of the low-bid system
and lack of oversight stretch far beyond
one contractor
and three communities and these are just
some of the challenges contributing to
water insecurity on first nations
some communities lack pipes to connect
treatment plans to homes
while others have trouble retaining
certified water operators
but as our reporting further illustrates
what connects all of these chronic
issues
are the colonial structures in place
that impede the development of these
communities
and the delivery of basic services like
clean drinking water
we're still thought of as less than
human
as objects as things as a problem as an
issue that can be swept aside and but
you put them in the reserves and then
you can just ignore it
but we can't be ignored we are people
and we are people that live
within this country a nation of nations
we have a right and we need people to
help us
and get basic human rights
to all of our people because the
government isn't going to change
unless the voices of canadians and
indigenous people
speak up and make the government pause
and listen
and then change will come
next week on the new reality there is
just a
a lot of people that are succumbing to
false information because of covid and
us being in isolation a lot of people
are curious
they're alone so they're turning to
communities on the internet
people who tout conspiracy theory they
actually take advantage of people's
fears i don't feel it's wise to leave
these
people speaking unchecked it's
frightening it's
absolutely frightening
[Music]
that is the new reality for this week
i'm donna friesen
thanks for joining us
[Music]
you